[Musique]
le bon soir mardi 19 janvier bienvenue
dans le journal préparé par la rédaction
de tv 78 tout de suite les titres de
cette édition
la visite de nalliers hier à poissy la
ministre déléguée chargée de la ville
s'est rendu dans cette commune candidate
pour devenir cité éducative
ce label attribué par le gouvernement a
pour but de permettre à chaque enfant
d'être accompagné durant tout son
parcours éducatif quatre villes sont
déjà labellisés dans les yvelines lors
date initiale a été reportée les soldes
d'hiver débutent demain mercredi elle se
déroule jusqu'au 16 février prochain les
enseignes se prépare pour cette période
particulière en pleine épidémie est sous
la mesure du couvre-feu à 18 heures la
direction départementale de la
protection des populations est également
sur le qui vive et plus reportage à
dampierre en yvelines à la fin de ce
journal le domaine est en travaux depuis
plusieurs semaines la grille datant du
xviiie siècle s'est refaite récemment
une beauté elle a été posée dernièrement
sur place la ministre délégué à la ville
nadia s est donc de nouveau déplacé dans
les yvelines ce lundi une visite pour
échanger avec les acteurs locaux autour
du projet et des sites éducatifs ce
programme mis en place par le
gouvernement doit permettre un meilleur
accompagnement des jeunes de 3 à 25 ans
pour endiguer le décrochage scolaire
favoriser l'insertion professionnelle et
lutter contre la délinquance la belle
que souhaite recevoir la ville pierre
rigaud reiber sediag à 200 go et patrick
jacques de dixmude poissy pourrait faire
partie des futurs cité éducative
un programme qui vise à impliquer
l'intégralité des acteurs locaux dans
l'accompagnement éducatif des enfants
la ministre de la ville nadia et était
en visite dans la commune yvelinoise
pour étudier le projet les acteurs se
mettent ensemble se mettent autour d'une
table et réfléchissent à une méthode de
travail a aussi les divers
accompagnements que qui peuvent
mutualiser proposé pour servir le
parcours de l'enfant dans le cadre de sa
réussite scolaire
aujourd'hui déjà 80 cité éducative ont
été labellisés en france ce qui
représente 520 mille enfants accompagnés
les 12 17 ans doivent être les premiers
bénéficiaires de ce programme l'école le
sport la culture
les parents avec 7 cette épine dorsale
que pour présenter du cassiot nationale
peut être pour nous un élément
facilitateur qui n'a d'autre objectif
que de bien vivre ensemble
outre l'éducation nationale le but est
d'aider des initiatives locales déjà
existantes comme ici à la fabrique
numérique du fab lab qui a un objectif
simple tu est de former des jeunes donc
des 16-29 ans qui sont en échec scolaire
souvent déscolarisés qui n'ont pas eu le
bac voilà pour essayer de susciter une
vocation ou de les aider avec les outils
qu'on h sur place vers une formation
plus poussée ou un emploi dernier axe du
projet cité éducative la sécurité un
comité de prévention de la délinquance
s'est tenue dans la journée autour de la
table les acteurs locaux ont présenté
leurs idées pour lutter contre la
délinquance en travaillant avec les
associations travaillant avec les
services de police
les collectivités la collectivité locale
et ses élus l'éducation nationale et
donc c'est comment tout le monde se
mobilise pour lutter efficacement contre
la délinquance
six poids s'ils venaient à bénéficier de
cette aide la ville toucherait 450000
euros de l'état pour la mise en place de
ce projet
j - en avant les soldes d'hiver cette
année l'événement va être bouleversée en
raison du contexte couvre-feu à 18h
gestion plus difficile les stocks les
magasins elles doivent s'adapter pendant
un mois le reportage de michael et demi
d'euros comme chaque année les
aficionados de la mode attendent ce
moment avec impatience les soldes
d'hiver débutent ce mercredi 20 janvier
en france on va être là à 6 heures du
matin carrément où les prix baissent
c'est toujours intéressant
moi ça me tente mais bon après voilà il
faut que les finances suivent cette
année le contexte sanitaire va
bouleverser le mode de fonctionnement
des magasins ce sera le cas dans cette
boutique de 110 m² implantés à plaisir
ici et les horaires seront adaptés pour
respecter le couvre-feu à 18 heures
cette décision pourrait avoir un impact
sur les ventes fermer des magasins 17h30
alors qu'on les ferme à 20h en règle
générale en moyenne il est certain que
pour le textile spécial spécifiquement
pour nous
c'est ce créneau horaire va être avant
de grosses incidences non moi je pense
qu'on sera entre je pense qu'on va
perdre entre 30 et 40% du chiffre pas
vous cacher qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas
serein par rapport à ça ralentit le
bretonneux cette boutique doit également
modifier ses habitudes
aucun cdd elle a été créée pour la
période des soldes dès les premiers
jours les décotes seront plus
importantes pour atteindre les prix
d'une deuxième démarque
enfin les stocks sont également moins
important par rapport aux années
précédentes
nous avons une table importants mobile
et un petit murale très léger ça fait
déjà quelques années que ça diminue ça
diminue ça diminue mais là avec la
conjoncture et les locaux vides
forcément les stocks sont encore moins
important mais seuls de divers se
termineront le 16 février prochain les
français devraient dépenser en moyenne
près de 319 euros lors de ce rendez vous
et on continue à parler de ce sujet avec
jean-bernard baridon qui étaient avec
nous par visioconférence bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le directeur départemental de
la protection des populations dans les
yvelines alors parmi vos missions
notamment celle d'assurer la protection
économique et la sécurité du
consommateur
de quelle manière et par quelles actions
justement assurez-vous cette mission
leur s'agissant des soldes nous avons
une action qui se fait en dotant une
action donc avant le démarrage des
soldes puisque nous sommes très présents
notamment sur internet
jusqu'aujourd'hui il est un des ports de
l'activité sur internet en ce qui
concerne l'activité commerciale est
ensuite durant la période de soldes
procédant à des contrôles contrôle qui
porte sur la réalité des réductions qui
sont proposés à la clientèle contrôle
qui porte sur l'achalandage
je rappelle que les soldes ne peuvent
porter que sur des marchandises qui ont
été acquises il ya au moins un mois
et donc il n'est pas possible durant la
période de soldes donc de se
réapprovisionner
il ya également des contrôles qui porte
sur la réalité et de la réduction de
prix puisque certains commerces en ligne
commerce in situ ont tendance à avoir
des affichages extrêmement généreux et
on se rend compte lors des contrôles
en réalité certains produits sont pas
stockées et puis on s'assurer une fine
et que le commerçant à pied que
réellement là la réduction de prix sur
un prix qu'il n'a pas modifié avant la
période de soldes et ça c'est important
c'est important de le préciser c'est une
période de bonnes affaires pour les
consommateurs de réduction des stocks ça
permet à d'écouler les stocks aussi pour
les commerçants mais vous le disiez qui
est aussi sous le contrôle de plusieurs
règles essentielles pendant cette seule
pendant cette période de soldes on a
compris une période de vigilance accrue
pour vous c'est un moment aussi
particulier un forcément avec cette
crise sanitaire dont on reparlera tout à
l'heure cette année d'ailleurs les
soldes ont été retardés elles vont se
dérouler donc du 20 janvier jusqu'au 16
février inclus initialement c'était
prévu du 6 janvier au 2 février ce que
vous pouvez rappeler pourquoi il ya eu
ce report
c'est tout simplement l'effet de la de
la pandémie que nous connaissons donc il
y a eu un report de 15 jours de la date
des soldes
ce qui fait que la période de soldes ne
portera plus que sur quatre semaines et
non pas six semaines comme initialement
prévu
et s'agissant de l'activité en magasin
nous sommes évidemment en vigilant au
respect du protocole sanitaire qui était
mis en place avec par exemple une jauge
de 8 mètres carrés par par client avec
la définition d'un nombre maximum de
personnes au magasin et une vigilance
accrue et professionnels mais les
professionnels ne sont pas les seuls à
avoir des responsabilités en la matière
les la clientèle aussi être honnêtes
faire preuve de civisme et ne pas se
jeter de com de manière un peu considéré
comme cela peut-être se faisait les
années précédentes
j'entendais l'une par le reportage que
certains vont se lever tôt pour aller
faire les soldes
il faudra quand même va être
particulièrement vigilants au port du
masque au gel et elle avoue respect des
prescriptions proposés par les
professionnels et professionnels ne
peuvent pas tout tous seuls on vous
parliez tout à l'heure des règles
pendant cette période de soldes vous
avez parlé notamment
de la gestion des stocks alors le fait
de ne pas pouvoir se réapprovisionner
pendant cette période il ya aussi une
distinction claire qui doit être faite
entre les nouvelles collections et les
les produits soldés c'est ça on doit
pouvoir le consommateur doit pouvoir
voir très très clairement une
distinction claire entre les articles
soldés les articles non soldés
évidemment certains entretiennent
l'ambiguïté mai dans les boutiques les
enseignes les plus sérieuses on voit
bien apparaître une nouvelle collection
sur d'autres portant sur d'autres êtres
lagière sachant et je voudrais insister
là dessus parce que je n'ai pas fui
suffisamment le les sols de son très
importante aussi sur internet
et sachant que sur internet on achète 24
heures sur 24 et que l'on est protégé
par la loi sur l'économie numérique
donc nous sommes très très vigilants sur
ce mode de commercialisation des
produits sachant qu'il y a environ 200
sites actifs aujourd'hui est que les
achats sur internet ça concerne environ
40 millions de personnes en france est
de l'ordre de 30 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires
donc la vigilance pour dire aussi que
même si c'est une période de soldes la
règle qui consiste à dire que les
échanges et les remboursements serait
peut-être différent c'est pendant cette
période de soldes ça il faut la mettre
de côté ses les mêmes garanties il ya de
l'échangé du remboursement qui est
garanti pendant cette période ce sont
les mêmes garanties
sachant que là le professionnel s'engage
sur une garantie de conformité donc si
nos produits que vous achetez vous
pensez avoir acheté du polyester
il se trouve que c'est de la laine vous
pouvez leur apporter parce que vous avez
bénéficié de cette garantie de
conformité
après il se peut que d'abord les soldes
ne sont pas obligatoires les
professionnels ne sont pas tenus de
faire des soldes même si cette année le
font pour des raisons de trésorerie
évidente mais chaque fin ne peut mettre
en place des conditions générales de
vente un petit peu spécifique à cette
occasion notamment dans le textile
souvent dans le textile le toucher sont
payantes alors qu'elles ne le sent pas
le reste les abus et les fraudes sont
elles récurrentes pendant cette période
justement est ce que vous avez peut-être
des chiffres en la matière sur le
département d
des yvelines sur les infractions qui ont
pu faire le relevé des yvelines
nous sommes quand même dans une logique
et une logique éminemment pédagogique
elle puisque ce sont des des pratiques
buntschu au fil du temps bon an mal an
il ya une dizaine simplement de
procédure pénale qui soit en te rédigé à
l'encontre des professionnels toutes les
anomalies que nous constatons nous les
gérons sous l'angle d'une injonction de
mise en conformité et 95 x ou 99 fois
sur 100 le professionnel est ce qu'on
lui demande de faire et un dernier mot à
vous les en a parlé tout à l'heure
jean-bernard baridon sur cette période
aussi particulière de de crise sanitaire
avec des protocoles qui sont mises en
place dans les commerces yvelinois vous
en avez parlé tout à l'heure votre rôle
aussi c'est de veiller au bon respect de
ce protocole sanitaire peut être en
faisant quelques contrôles alors tous
les services de l'état qui sont
desservis sur le terrain police en armes
et la ddpp de serre a évidemment tout au
long de la période où nous accompagnons
nos contrôles d'une action pédagogique
auprès des professionnels
et s'il s'avère que les professionnels
sont vraiment entre guillemets hors la
loi nous leur adressons une agence temps
de se mettre en conformité des délais
qui sont des délais extrêmement de boer
qui peuvent être des délais 24 et 48
heures merci jean bernard baryton
d'avoir été avec nous par
visioconférence merci je le rappelle
vous êtes le directeur départemental de
la protection des populations donc dans
les yvelines et je rappelle cette date 1
celle des soldes d'hiver qui débutent
demain mercredi c'est du 20 janvier au
16 février inclus pour cette période de
soldes d'hiver
ce geste solidaire à présent ce début
d'année à triel sur seine les habitants
de la commune ont remis hier lundi de
nombreux cadeaux à une association cette
association c'est les enfants de la
terre elle vient en aide aux enfants en
difficulté ces dons vont pouvoir être
distribués aux jeunes qui sont
hospitalisés le reportage d'eléonore
sinoquet de lucas d'arundel des ce qu'un
cours de condé c'est à l'espace ce n'est
que la municipalité de triel sur seine a
remis de nombreux cadeaux à
l'association les enfants de la terre
lundi 18 janvier une collecte qui a été
fait en décembre par les habitants
eux-mêmes avec le soutien du collectif
triel solidarité les landes soja
d'arrêter a duré trois semaines
c'est à dire tous les week-ends il y
avait une des collègues qui étaient
régulières sur la ville on avait aussi
bien aux châtelaine qu'en bord de seine
et avec cette collecte
il ya eu déjà une salle complète donc ça
me représente
il ya 80 mètres carrés qui était
entièrement plein de cadeaux donc
vraiment c'était impressionnant
ça a été déjà redistribué à plusieurs
associations caritatives dont les restos
du coeur secours catholique est
aujourd'hui donc c'est les enfants de la
terre basé à thiverval grignon et créé
il y à 33 ans par marie claire perrier
la mère de yannick noah
l'association est aujourd'hui présidée
par sa soeur nathalie les enfants de la
terre vient en aide aux enfants en
difficultés sociales et économiques en
france ou encore en afrique
ça me fait chaud au coeur et vous cache
pas que c'est la première fois qu'on a
une collecte comme ça c'est très rare en
général les gens donnent souvent des cdd
des jouets d'occasion
ce qui est très bien mais là c'est voilà
je pense que c'est un vrai noël un vrai
noël qu'on va faire passer à plein de
petits enfants beaucoup dans les
hôpitaux beaucoup à
tall debré beaucoup dans les hôpitaux et
je pense qu'il ya deux trois cadeaux que
j'ai déjà vu j'en ai vélo qu'on pourra
pas mal dans les hôpitaux donc là on les
offrira dans les maisons tendresse qu'on
a ce petit village c'est la première
fois qu'on a une collecte aussi belle et
aussi au temps de jouer tout en
s'adaptant à la crise sanitaire
l'association démarre aura les premières
distributions de cadeaux dans les
hôpitaux
samedi 23 janvier solidarité toujours
avec cette course virtuelle j'enfile mes
baskets pour les ana qui se déroulera à
partir de ce samedi 23 janvier un
événement caritatif pour l'association
au fil de les annales et anas est une
petite fille atteinte d'une maladie rare
qui a besoin de votre aide notamment
pour financer du matériel médical c'est
parents ont répondu aux questions des
léonore sinoquet c'est le principe d'une
course virtuelle donc les gens en fait
longtemps inscrire sur le site de
protéines ming ils ont le choix de
réaliser soit une course soit une marge
de 5 ou 10 km donc ils réalisent entre
le 23 janvier le 7 février
donc c'est un euro du kilomètre on a mis
en place six types de courses 5 km
marche marche nordique et course et 10
km marche marche nordique et course et
donc les gens pour 5 km 5 euros et 50
centimes de frais d'inscription
on envisage de financer un vélo cargo
alors on avait déjà fait une première
cagnotte mais veille au cargö il faut
savoir ça ça coûte entre kas et 5000
euros
donc on n'avait pas eu suffisamment donc
on a mis de côté l'argent qu'on avait
déjà récupéré là on espère pouvoir
compléter financement oui bah on va la
faire donc avec ses frères dans les
annales sera dans une joie net
et puis on va se relayer voilà tous mes
quatre pour pour la pousser donc
qu'elles profitent de ce moment là parce
qu'elle adore vraiment la sensation de
vitesse et de mouvement sur sur la route
donc comme ça on va pouvoir tous le
faire avec les enfants du sport
également dans l'actualité avec
l'annoncé aujourd'hui du ministère des
sports concernant la coupe de france de
football les clubs amateurs encore
engagés dans la compétition peuvent
désormais reprendre les entraînements
collectifs pour se préparer
c'est une autorisation en vue du sixième
tour de la coupe de france de football
qui est programmée le week end des 30 et
31 janvier pour rappel un représentant
yvelinois est encore en lice et conflans
qui recevra l'équipe de vitry sur seine
est les rencontres seront à huit clos et
chaque joueur devra effectuer un test
pcr ou antigénique deux à trois jours
avant le match en cas de mise à
l'isolément de tout ou partie de son
effectif ou défaut de tests l'équipe en
question sera éliminé par forfait une
coupe de france exceptionnellement à
deux tableaux cette année amateurs et
professionnels elle ne se retrouveront
cette année au costa des 16e de finale
les seizièmes de finale programmée fin
février ou début mars
cet événement prévu en novembre dernier
avait dû être reporté la grande blague
rendent bad braderie je vais y arriver
du golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines s'est tenue du 15 au 17 janvier
à les programmer deux fois par an sur le
site installé à guyancourt
sur place les golfeurs et non golfeurs
ont pu retrouver du textile des
chaussures encore des clubs et des
réductions jusqu'à moins 60 % étaient
proposées malgré une météo neigeuse
samedi les visiteurs étaient au
rendez-vous les propos recueillis par
bixente mais rien senti steban ya eu
beaucoup de monde vendredi beaucoup de
monde hier malgré la neige le goal fermé
gens sont quand même venus est là
aujourd'hui à du monde aussi donc oui on
est content et nos clients aussi
on est venu pour se promener parce qu'il
n'est pas très beau et je pensais qu'on
n'aurait pas pu jouer au golf
aujourd'hui à cause de la neige
et puis finalement on a fait des achats
c'est un événement annuel qu'on connaît
qu'on coach tous les ans parce
qu'effectivement on aime dialoguer le
dolce nationale les collections qu'ils
ont poussé sont des événements qui sont
intéressants je vous le disais dans les
titres les travaux du domaine de
dampierre en yvelines se poursuivre
malgré quelques ralentissements dus au
confinement
la semaine dernière la dépose de la
grille rénovée habib ben a bien pu avoir
lieu le reportage de célia gars tsongo
et de sable saad
tout un symbole la grille d'honneur du
domaine de dampierre à dampierre en
yvelines va se refaire une beauté
mercredi 13 janvier a eu lieu la dépose
d'un des deux vantaux par les ateliers
saint jacques de la fondation de
coubertin à l'instauration consiste
d'abord à une recherche stratigraphique
des couches de peinture pour identifier
les finitions ensuite on démons
l'ensemble des pièces qui composent cet
ouvrage
et on les restaurants la grille a été
installé par le duc de luynes au xviiie
siècle
elle n'a jamais eu de restauration
aujourd'hui évidemment elle souffre de
l'usure de la rouille qui l'a attaqué
les couleurs qui ne sont plus des des
commandes et assemblage qui ont cassé la
grille d'honneur sera de nouveau au
domaine dans deux ans en attendant dans
le château les charpentiers sont à pied
d'oeuvre pour faire les relevés en vue
de la restauration de la charpente
le château de dampierre a été construit
à la fin du xviie siècle et depuis cette
période il n'a subi qu'une seule
campagne de restauration qui est il ya
presque deux cents ans est évidemment
presque 200 ans après il était
nécessaire d'intervenir on voit les bois
des javas déjà la couverture les
ardoises était à bout de souffle
on voit les coûts les charpentes qui
sont abîmés les chevrons qui sont cassés
des éléments qui sont exposés au zoo
même si sur l'abri des plombs qui sont
pourris le chantier global atteint près
de 50 millions d'euros et sera terminée
courant 2022 sur le logis avant de vous
laisser noter que demain mercredi c'est
l'ouverture des voeux sur la plateforme
parcours sup à cette occasion l'académie
de versailles propose un live sur
instagram à destination des lycéens une
initiative qui se déroulera désormais
chaque mois le principe le live est
animé par un élève
élu au conseil académique pour la vie
lycéenne avec un invité les spectateurs
pourront lui poser directement leurs
questions en direct demain mercredi
c'est raphaël lartigou chef du service
académique de l'information et de
l'orientation qui répondra à vos
questions sur parcours suppl rendez vous
sur le compte instagram de l'académie de
versailles à partir de 18h voilà c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité dans un instant on retrouvait
un nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
présentée par justine brasier très belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]